let's start with the most interesting method, in the checkAnswer method, I am
given the response which is a string, I convert it to a number by calling
DoubleparseDouble and now I check whether that number is close enough to the
actual answer, we've learned in lesson four how to do that, we take the
difference of the two numbers that you want to compare, take the absolute
value. And check whether that's most the given tolerance. Now, there's just one
catch. What's this answer here? Well, it's whatever was supplied in the set
answer method. Interestingly, the set answer method here takes a double, so
it's not a string. And that means it's different from the set answer method
that was defined in the question class. That method took a string. Now I
could've converted this number into a string, and then passed it on to the
setAnswer method of the question class, and let the question store it as a
string, and then I could've converted it back from a string to a number, I
suppose, except when I tried that it didn't work, because the question class
has no way of giving me back the answer. It's used inside it's own check answer
method. But that one is worthless to me, because it doesn't take the tolerance
into account. So instead, I just store the answer as a double in the numeric
question.